bientôt la fin de la saison de la
croisière dans notre région et les
autorités touristiques en dresse déjà un
premier bilan positif ce qui n'est pas
pour déplaire à le des acteurs du
développement de cette activité le grand
port maritime de martinique bonjour jean
rémy villageois bon genre mon résultat
vous êtes le directeur de ce grand port
vous personnellement
oseriez vous parlez de saison
exceptionnelle pour ce secteur du
tourisme de croisière
oui tout à fait exceptionnelle à plus
d'un titre d'abord en termes de chiffres
on va passer les cinq cent mille
passagers donc on rentre vraiment dans
le dans le club des plus de 500000 donc
qu'on voit la confronte change de
catégorie
une croissance qui était prévu on avait
travaillé et en plus de ça on a eu des
événements exceptionnels puisqu'on a
reçu un apport de navires qui était pas
prévu d'en bas il ya et hermann à
martigues part de très loin concernant
ces chiffres est chaud puisque on va
quand même le rappeler il y avait quatre
cent mille visiteurs dans le début des
années 90 il y en avait chuté à passer à
moins de 50000 visiteurs il y a à peine
quelques années il y à peine sept ans
effectivement en 2011 on était à 50
mille passagers c'était très mauvais une
longue descente aux enfers entre les
deux début des années 90 et puis cesser
ces années 2010 2011 avant de remonter
une remontée qui s'est exercée au tour
de 2012 2013
on passe progressivement de 50 mille
passagers deux cent mille trois cent
mille cinq cent mille et donc on voit
bien que la martinique rattrape son
retard le port rattrape son retard la
destination remonte en puissance
progressivement et ça s'est très très
bien alors je rémy villageois vous dites
que sept succès mais pour qui finalement
pour quel secteur uniquement pour le
secteur de croisière cet argent cette
manne financière bénéficie à qui alors
justement la question c'est s'agit-il
d'une manne financière à qui ça rapporte
quel est l'impact sur l'île et pourquoi
tous ces investissements donc c'est les
questions que se sont posées
l'ensemble des acteurs pack seulement le
grand port maritime et le comité
martiniquais du tourisme idea
les industriels et des entrepreneurs
regroupés au sein du groupement pour du
tourisme de la martinique est le jtc m
donc tous ces acteurs se sont regroupés
ont travaillé avec l'afd pour évaluer
l'impact économique du tourisme de
croisière alors aux touristes de croiser
un général ils achètent un package c'est
un séjour sur un bateau où tout est
fourni il a tout fourni comme on dit
chez nous pourquoi dépend serait-il de
l'argent à terek est ce qu'on est ce
qu'on a envie d'acheter lorsqu'on nie
tout le touriste de croiser quand
débarque à fort de france alors
effectivement le les destinations font
partie d'un package chaque escale fait
partie d'une d'un tour et effectivement
les gens cherchent des choses
différentes en fonction des îles qu'il
touche et en fonction de la tente qu'ils
ont et donc effectivement le touriste
qui descend du bateau à fort de france
et à la martinique va va chercher
quelque chose de différent de ce qu'ils
trouvent dans les autres îles donc il va
chercher à visiter à explorer il va être
intéressés par la culture
on voit bien que l'image qu'ont les
américains 1 2 de la martinique c'est
une île où il ya une culture il ya
quelque chose de particulier donc c'est
ça qui vont chercher et c'est ça qu'il
faut leur donner il faut fonds anciens
vous l'avez quantifier cela alors oui
c'est quantifier un les dépenses
moyennes par croisière y sont que sont
connus sont évaluées sont comparés à
chaque année pour la martinique on est
donc en moyenne à 80 euros
un autour de contre 81 70 euros et les
passagers en à différents types de
passagers on a des passages et de
transit et donc c'est des gens qui
descendent à la journée cela dépenses
somme toute assez peu ils sont à 50 60
dollars alors que les passagers qui
embarquent donc ceux qui viennent
d'europe et qui prennent le bateau à
fort de france la dépense beaucoup plus
là on est autour de 150 et c'est cela
qu'il faut choyer et si il faut comparer
par exemple une autre île de de la zone
caraïbe par exemple samart alors saint
martin fait partie des destinations
shopping
donc ce sont des destinations où les où
les gens vont pour acheter
des choses des montres des bijoux des
choses comme ça donc les dépenses sont
bien naturellement beaucoup plus élevé
on joue pas du tout dans cette catégorie
et pourquoi déjà tout simplement parce
qu'on n'a pas cette offre de shopping
c'est un choix qui a été fait il ya
quelques années on est plutôt sur une
destination touristique une destination
qui vend la beauté de son île des
excursions des visites dans les dents
les dans les distilleries
donc on vend autre chose on vend des
choses qui sont produites localement
oui on vend des choses qui sont moins
chers qui sont plus accessibles donc la
dépense est moins importante
une montre de luxe achetées par exemple
à saint martin cette somme est investie
sur cette montre ne reste pas à ma
retraite tandis qu'un d'euros dépasse et
des penseurs martic ça reste un martini
alors il faut savoir qu'un euro dépensé
à saint martin il en reste 20 centimes
puisque évidemment ce sont des choses
avaient très cher mais mais qui reste
pas dans l'île alors que ici un euro
dépensé rapporte à peu près 70 centimes
qui reste sur l'île donc ça c'est très
important et très efficace en fait en
termes de dépenses et en termes de
d'argent qui reste dans la destination
ça c'est très important vous avez la
possibilité de savoir cela très
exactement très précisément senti prêt
oui parce que les dépenses des
croisiéristes sont répertoriés et sont
classés en fonction du type de dépenses
et donc on évalue très bien les appétits
économiques vous savez sur croisiéristes
acheter un sandwich chez dans une petit
rouleau tous il a commencé à consommer
dans une franchise connue alors on va
pas aller jusque là mais on connaît la
dépense moyenne des croisiéristes en
tout cas ans et les comparer tous les
pays tous les grands ports cherche à
évaluer ça et à se comparer donc c'est
bien évidemment des choses qui existent
alors on dit que ce qui est bon pour le
tourisme de croisière et
valable pour l'ensemble de l'île et vous
avez même avancé un chiffre
jean-rémy villageois vous dites que par
exemple un euro investi par le grand
port de martinique
c'est en euros 3,2 rapporté pour
l'ensemble de l'île
oui tout à fait là on parle d
investissement du port donc lorsque le
port engage des investissements ils sont
importants il faut rappeler que sur la
croisière c'est de l'ordre de 10
millions d'euros plus un million d'euros
chaque année donc c'est des
investissements qui sont qu'ils sont
majeurs et qui sont continues qui sont
principalement dans le btp et donc il
essaie se lasser c'est connu c'est
évaluer ses investissements l'un reste
dans l'île parce que c'est de la main
d'oeuvre
ce sont des matériaux qui sont produits
localement et donc voilà il ya un très
fort impact sur l'économie de l'île et
que dites vous donc à toutes ces
personnes qui disent que le tourisme ne
rapporte pas finalement 3 à lille ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut regarder de
plus près c'est à dire qu'il faut
dépasser en fait les les intuitions où
les impressions il faut chiffrer les
choses c'est pour ça qu'on a mené cette
étude de grosses boîtes statistiques qui
le disent à un moment oui mais il faut
s'il faut voir que tous les tous les
pores toutes les villes portuaires
engage ce genre d'étude et essayent
d'évaluer finement ce que ça leur
rapporte parce que c'est beaucoup
d'investissement
donc il s'agit d'évaluer l'impact
économique la rentabilité réelle de
façon à décider des politiques publiques
alors vous dites un euro investi chez le
polo grand pour 5 euros 3 pour
l'ensemble de la martinique vous
chercher à optimiser ce que vous avez
déjà des pistes de travail pour que ce
sera beaucoup plus plus favorable ce
ratio alors il faut optimiser je dirais
mais pas que on est dans un
environnement qui est extrêmement
concurrentiel il faut savoir qu'on se
bat sur la caraïbe sud
avant il ya quelques années on faisait
six fois moins de touristes que cinq
l'uci est à peu près trois fois moins
que barbade
on a remonté donc on est aujourd'hui à
peu près au même niveau donc la
concurrence est très très forte dans
cette zone caraïbes sud et donc il va
falloir se battre pour garder nos
touristes
et puis pour progressivement leur antre
de plus en plus intéressant donc
travaillé sur la dépense moyenne
travailler sur le type de dépenses est
en fait répondre aux attentes des
croisiéristes et c'est comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir tenir notre et se disant est ce
dire aussi que ce qui est arrivé à la
dominique site et rita saint martin peut
nous arriver également oui tout à fait
il faut vraiment se rendre compte que on
est dans un environnement qui est non
seulement concurrentiel et volatil mais
aussi extrêmement vulnérables donc il
faut que nos infrastructures soit de bon
niveau pour pouvoir résister mais des
fois il ya des choses qui vont se passer
un qui sont qui nous dépasse largement
et donc il faut s'attendre à des as des
as des problèmes il faut être prêt à ça
jean-rémy villageois le grand port c'est
également cette activité pétrolier
également cette année cette activité des
conteneurs il ya le bassin de radoub
doivent poser une question très simple
est ce que le grand port est devenu un
espace vraiment sortu arisée les
conflits que l'on connaissait est ce que
ça existe toujours mais ça fait partie
du passé
alors le port reste le port bien
évidemment c'est une zone où il ya
beaucoup d'activités c'est une activité
qui augmentent régulièrement
il y à des tensions mais on se parle il
ya un dialogue social qui fournit les
gens se rencontrent les gens sont fiers
de leur boulot mais ils défendent aussi
leur position donc ça reste quand même
une terre de voilà deux des changes
viril un effort donc
voilà le port reste le port mais il est
reconnu de plus en plus comme un porc
qui est de plus en plus flexible la
confiance revient la confiance des
armateurs la confiance des clients et ça
c'est très important
il est relationnel avec nos amis dockers
alors le relationnel idée il est il est
de tous les jours de tous les instants
sur les quais on se parle on y est on
n'est pas toujours d'accord mais on
travaille on travaille dans la même
direction est en tout cas pour le moment
les résultats sont là une dernière
question de l'extension du terminal
conteneurs ce alors que de choses qui
avancent
oui tout à fait et l'extension il
termine un conteneur faut rappeler que
c'est la majeure partie des marchandises
passent par container le port au présent
décret 98 % des échanges de livres et
une grande partie de ces échanges passe
par ce terminal qui étaient ceux qui
étaient sous dimensionné on n'est pas
assez grand pour recevoir les bateaux
donc une première phase d'extension a
été engagé il ya deux ans avec succès
elle a été livré en temps et en heure et
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne bien
la deuxième phase d'extension va
démarrer d'ici la fin de l'année il
s'agira d' a longé les quais tout
simplement pour s'adapter aux navires
qui sont de plus en plus grands et qui
viennent toucher d'investissement de
combien ça cette phase de travaux
alors la première phase de travaux était
de l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros la
deuxième phase on sera autour de 40
millions d'euros
merci d'avoir été se battait avec nous
aurait mis village rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur du grand port maritime
de la martinique et que vous
applaudissez ces bons chiffres du
tourisme de croisière merci d'abriter ce
matin dans son caddie bonne journée
merci bonne journée
[Musique]